[拍手]
[音楽]
日は伊藤と申します0
よろしくお願い致し
高本サラといい感じで硬かったが強くね
リラックスしていくだろうと思うんです
切り替わったら話
今日私からござい
は私たちの取り組み
競争主に4号する社会
を作りたいということでまぁ対面も高句麗
ついているわけなんですがどうしたら後方社会で作れるというところが私たちが終え
ヶ月増えているテーマでもあります
この方についてこれまでの取り組みの中でですねまぁ生麹で心配でたくさんありますの
で皆さんと共有しながら
一緒にの幸福理論うまくオペレーションしていけたらなというふうに考えておりますの
でどうぞよろしくお願い致します
今日はですね大きく
3つのトピックから話を進めようと思うんですが
一つ目が
被災者と支援者二つ目が提案者等
実行者そして三つ目が実行者と支援者ということなんですがこれはもうクリエイトの
過去現在未来に関係するトピックです
まずはじめに
被災者と支援者これはこのクリエイトができるまでの流れについて少し長やできたらと
思います
先ほどもう少しご紹介頂いた中にもあったんですね
私たちは東日本大震災をひっかけに生まれたら
市民団体です
皆さんは東日本大震災と聞いて
胴長名
道内思い浮かべますね
私にもいろいろ思川シーンがあるんです
今でも忘れないなぁ
近所に住んでいて旋盤前赤ちゃんを抱えたお母さんの必死な表情です
本当にあのー大変がないから
生まれたばかりの赤ちゃんを抱えてですね
頑張っている姿だったんですが私はそんな彼と地震がおさまった後ばったり会った時に
いろいろ声をかけながら大丈夫ですよなんて言いながら赤ちゃんを抱きかかえ
を買って制してたのですが
一つその時に大きな気づきがあります
これはないかというおおーー
あまりにも私たちは近所の人について知らないという事実なんですね
私はは最近コーツ配り歳研究ても震災前に着く前に移り住んだ人間の一人なんですが
やはりあの駅周辺というのは新しい人たちがお引越しも多いのでなかなか上がりていい
んじゃないかと思って知らないまま
日々生活している
まあそんな結果大震災の時に痛感したのが地域につながりのよはおおおおっ
結構ありのかも知らない名前は知っていても普段
オープンなコミュニケーションを取っていない
という自分ですか
私の住んでいるアパートはですねかなり揺れが広くてめちゃめちゃ上がってしまいまし
て
結局市役所に家族で避難しました
ビニールシートを外日に弾いてくれていたのでそこに私たちは数日間お世話になること
にあります
その時にですねまた一つ大きな気づきがあったんですが
自分は自分の事を被災者だって思ってるところが
少なからがあったんですね
まあかなり揺れて家にも進めないという状態で非難しました
でも一方で市役所で活躍されている皆さん
て自分自身も被災者なのに
ai クラインの復旧のためにとか地域住民のために出向いている方々が
はですね
つまり被災者なんですけどみんな支援者になる
取り組んでそういう状況を私が目にしましたん
さらに筑波大生が中心になった学生のボランティアチームがあってですね
最後必要な情報を収集してそれを fns を使って
発信するという取り組みもしてました彼らも被災者でありながら支援者では起こした一
羽ですよ
この後をプレゼンする中田君もそんな一人ですが
そんなメンバーとであるてですね私は大きくと考え方等を変えたという恥ずかしいなと
正直思います
まあひそれー者として預けてもらおうとしてた自分が少し難しかった
優待感が体験をしました
そこから少しずつ積極的に市民活動に時間を使うようになってい
まずはよりひどい被害のあった津波が被害のあった場所に行ってみようということで
亘理町宮城県亘理町に行ってみました本当に見渡す限りけどローズのような場所の中で
衣装懸命家の復旧のためにですね働いている人たちと
接していく中で本当に良いのいろんな人たちがいろんな想い
一応支援しているんだなという実感もあります
福島県いわき市にもですね何度か足を運んでいる
私でしたの
出身が福島ですので今でもたびたびに行きますが
子どもたちが遊んでいる工程にですね
沢山のがれきが積まれているまそんな風景を目にしました
いつになったら子どもたちはこの場でまた遊べるんだろうなぁ
思いながらいうところです
あとはできる限りですね被災地
まあなんですかね行く機会をつくろうということで今でも定期的にか服良好で福島だっ
たりこれは福島県裏磐梯磐梯そうなんですが描けるようにしています
そんな感じのエネルギーまでも伝えるし関わり続いて
茨城自体が被災地と言う
こともありますのでその想いを根底に持っている
ゆ
コンクリートのメンバーはその大震災直後にボランティア活動をしていたり何か地域の
ためにできないかって思った人たちが自然と集まって sns 上でつながって最終的
には団体を立ち上げたというような流れになっています
ここからはをクリエイトの電材をテーマに
提案者と実行者かというテーマで話を進めていきます
こうプレートの活動をコアの部分というのは非常にシンプルな活動になってまして
ソーシャルネットワーキングサービスや sns を使ってですね
市民の住んでいる方々からいろいろな提案をほらうこの地域にそんなものがあったら
いいなという提案をもらうんですね
もらった提案を腹に市民の人たちに投票してもらってどれが最も良い提案を選んでも
ん
いう活動です選んでもらった最終的に1位になった
提案を実際に市議会へ提案しようということをこれまで3回続けてきています
ただもうこの活動ですねいろいろ課題がありました
a まず最初の課題なんですが
そもそも sns を使っている市民のカバーって多くないというのが最初に口や鼻
からです
当時で大体は筑波してみ13万人住んでますがそのうち使っている方
私たちは主にベースブックを使ってなのですが大体5000人くらいしかいなかっ
なのでまずは使える人を支える市民の人を増やそうということで勉強会を定期的に開催
してきました
さらに
文章だけでの提案を読んでも聞いてこないという話もあるんですね
なので提案者とその提案に興味関心ある人が実際に話す機会を一緒にディスカッション
する機会をつくろうということで
そのような交流会も開催します
さらにえーっ
web 上でもディスカッションって
まあお互い顔が見えないというのもあってですね
実はじゃなかなかしにくいという声もありますこれは現在でも多大なんです
それ持ってリアルの場で交流する機会
まずはお互いオープンなコミュニケーションを取っ
星さまより知り合った上で web 上でディスカッションしましょう
いうことでリアルのまでの交流会に関して
そこから派生的にですね色んなイベントが生まれてきてこちらは神社で開いた読書会を
好きなんですが
リアルの場での交流がウェブ上につながり得る上での交流が当たりあるなく
の流れ
今起こってきている
そして私たちの活動の中心が今こちらにシフトしていっている
いうのが現状です
ます私たちのかつ本はまちづくりのベーアーの市議会に届けるというのが最初だったん
ですが
提案シーク中では結局その提案だけだとなかなかうまくいかないなというふうに生じ
あります
うん
行政の持っている特徴として行政機能の持っている特徴としては公平性とか正確性と
いうものを上げられると思うんですね
一方私たち市民がを持っている特徴といいますからね
市民の持ちとしては創造性だったら人測定というものがあるんじゃないかと思う
つまり思いついたアイディアをすぐに実行しようというのは市民の方がしやすく
1本用生の皆さんは
それは本当に公平なのかとか
大きなリスクはない関係のよく検証した上で動きだというところがありますのでお互い
の特徴を掛け合わせることでその町がですね
創造性やだから住みたい街にあるんじゃないという風に考えながらこれまで活動してき
たと言う
ただ先ほどちょっと触れたんですがこの渇望には課題があります
提案する人と実行する人が別々なんですね
このままに経営者の思いが熟考者にあまり使わずに集まり市民や提案したものを矯正の
方に実行してもらおうと思った部分
そもそもなんでそれは必要なのか
本当に入るのって言うところのすり合わせには膨大な力をそがれてしまうというのが
あります
なので今私たちを持っている結論としては
提案者候補
実行者は=であったほうがいいだろうつまり思いを持った人が
思いを実現するために自分で行動そのためのさん今日我々が整え
有用な活動がこの街にあったらいいんじゃないかな
いうことで今日の霊が憑くをしてきています
最後のトピックが実行者等支援車
これは工グリーとの未来についての話
私たちは誰しも第2章なにいろんなアイディア
台下に対する想いを持って生きている
思います